Then he mentioned
the chapter on what is warned against regarding the allure of this world and competing for it, as narrated by Al-Bukhari, may God have mercy on him.
He mentioned the hadith of Ibn Shihab on the authority of Urwah ibn Al-Zubayr,
that Al-Miswar ibn Makhrama informed him
that Amr ibn Awf was an ally of Banu Amir ibn Lu'ayy. He had
participated in the Battle of Badr with the Messenger of God, may
God bless him and grant him peace. He was informed that the Messenger of God, may God
bless him and grant him peace, sent Abu Ubaydah ibn Jarrah to Bahrain to collect its tribute. Here, it is explained that the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
sent Abu Ubaydah ibn Jarrah to Bahrain. The Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, was the one who made peace with the people of Bahrain, may God bless him and grant him peace, and appointed Al-Ala' from the city as their leader. Abu Ubaydah arrived with money from Bahrain.
The Ansar heard of his arrival and met him at the
morning prayer with the Messenger of God, may
God bless him and grant him peace. When he finished, they approached him, may God bless him and grant him peace. The
Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, smiled when he saw him and
said, "I think you have heard of the arrival of Abu Ubaydah and that he has brought
something." They said, "
Yes, O Messenger of God, he is
not the Messenger of God."
He said, "Rejoice, rejoice, and hope for what pleases you. By God, I do not..."
I fear poverty for you,
but I fear that worldly riches will be bestowed upon you
as they were bestowed upon those before you, and that you will compete for them as they competed for them, and that they will be destroyed and you will be destroyed as they were
destroyed.
[Music] Or that they will be distracted as they were. The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said here that he is warning against being seduced by worldly riches and competing for them. God, peace and blessings be upon him, told them here that he does not fear poverty for them,
but rather that the greatest trial is wealth,
because the harm of poverty is
mostly worldly, while the harm of wealth is
mostly religious, diverting you from the religion of God. One becomes seduced by worldly riches,
neglects zakat, and falls into usury.
All of this is from the conditions of the wealthy.
This shows that whoever has been granted worldly riches and
God has given him of its goodness
must beware of its bad consequences and the evil of its trials. It also shows
that one of the greatest causes of trials is wealth and
money. It
also shows the generosity of the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, and
his concern for his companions when he gave them from this
wealth, peace and blessings be upon him.
Also, what makes one fearful in this hadith is that the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, feared for his companions, so what about our condition
and the condition of  May
God Almighty protect him.
[Music]
Then he mentioned the hadith of Uqbah ibn Amir that the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
went out one day and prayed over the people of
Uhud as he would pray over the dead.
Amir, may God be pleased with him, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
Turning towards the pulpit, he said, “
I am your forerunner, and I am a witness over you. By God, I am
looking at my cistern right now, and I have been
given the keys to the treasures of the earth, or the keys to the earth.
[Music] By God, I do not fear that you will associate partners with God after me, but I fear that you will compete for them.” [Music]
This hadith also
shows the
Prophet’s, may God bless him and grant him peace, fear for his companions
regarding the world and competition.
[Music] It
also shows one of the signs of prophethood,
which is his foretelling of the unseen. “I have been given the keys to the treasures of the
earth” refers to the conquests
that will occur after him, may
God bless
him and grant him peace. His saying “your forerunner” means the one who will precede you to the cistern. This
also includes belief in the cistern of our Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace.
As for the meaning of his saying, “By
God, I do not fear that you will associate partners with God after me,” the polytheists used it as evidence that
polytheism cannot occur in the cistern.  The
Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) said that the worship of idols, such as Dhu al-Khalasa, would return
to the Arabian Peninsula, but this is a false understanding. The Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) informed us that idol worship would return to the Arabian Peninsula,
for example. The
meaning of the hadith is that no one will commit idolatry, not that the
entire Muslim community will be involved in idolatry.
[Music]
Or perhaps it refers specifically to the Companions of the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him), meaning that no one will commit idolatry among them.
Also included in this hadith is his statement, "He prayed
for the people of Uhud."
Here, the discussion concerns the issue of praying for a martyr:
should it be done or not?
[Music]
The correct view, which is the opinion of the majority of scholars, is that a
martyr is not prayed for, just as the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) did not pray for the people of Uhud
when they were martyred.
[Music] The
meaning of the hadith, as mentioned by al-Shafi'i, al-Nawawi, and
others, is
that this occurred eight years later,
as stated in some narrations. The
meaning of "prayer" here is supplication
and seeking forgiveness for them.
Then, yes, he mentioned the hadith of Abu Sa'id al-Khudri, in which the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him)
said... [Music]
Al-Khudri, may God be pleased
with him, narrated a
hadith from the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him: “What I
fear most for you is what God brings forth for you from the blessings of the
earth.” The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said, “The blessings of the earth.” A
man asked, “Does good come from
evil?” The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, remained silent until I thought that revelation would descend upon him. Then he began wiping his forehead, peace and blessings be upon him, and said, “Where is the questioner?” He said, “I am Sulayman Abu Sa’id. We loved him when he was born.” The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, “Good only comes from good.” This wealth is like a sweet fruit.
[Music]
And every time it sprouts,
it kills by bloating
or poisoning, except for the greens.
[Music] The concept of vegetation,
such as eating, is like a stomach that faces the sun and starts to regurgitate and passes out, and then goes to eat again.
This life is
like sweet fruit, and if a person earns it in the best way and spends it properly,
it is excellent. And whoever earns it in the best way will be
like
the one who eats but is never satisfied.
This hadith is from the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.  And he
said, “What I fear most for you is what
comes out of the blessings of the earth. Among the blessings of the
earth is the flower of this world.” The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, “The blessings of this flower.” So
the questioner asked, “
If the flower of this worldly life is a blessing from
God, how can these blessings bring evil?” This is a place
[of music]. And he, peace and blessings be upon him, explained that
people are of two
kinds regarding this blessing and this world. The first is the
man who was
excessive in accumulating worldly possessions and they distracted him from the Hereafter. This is the one who
ate everything that grows on the earth until his stomach was full of bloating,
or he suffered from bloating.
This eating harmed him. This is the one who accumulates worldly possessions and whose main concern is this
world. The first category
is that man who went to access the blessings of the world and they
distracted him from the Hereafter, so he
ate and consumed everything
from the world and his main concern was the world and the world. The other is the one who forgets his share of this world,
but he was moderate
in accumulating it and benefiting from it. He was not
like the first one who ate from it until his stomach was bloated. The
hadith condemns extravagance. And among the
benefits of the hadith, as mentioned at the end, is that whoever takes
this  This money, acquired
unlawfully, will
not be blessed. He
eats but does not drink.
[Music]
Yes. Then he mentioned the hadith of Imran ibn Husayn, may God be pleased with him, on the authority of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, who
said: “The best of you are my generation, then those who follow
them, then those who follow them.”
The hadith of Imran ibn Husayn, may God be pleased with him, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him.
Imran said, “I do not know.” The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said
after mentioning two or three generations, meaning he
mentioned two or three generations, peace and blessings be upon him, “
Then there will come after them a people who will bear witness without being asked, who will betray
without being consulted, who will make vows without betraying, and
among them will appear the sky.”
In this hadith is a
statement of the excellence of the Companions and their superiority, both collectively and individually,
over all who came after them. As for
the generations after them, such as the Successors and the Followers of the
Successors, their excellence is based on their collective merit, not on
their individual merits. The
Successors
mean that no one will ever come after the Companions of the
Messenger of God who is better than the Companions of the Messenger of God, or
better than one of the Companions of the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him,
even if he is one of the senior Successors. However, the
Successors are better than those who came after them, but there may
come someone from among those who are better than some of the Successors.
So what was mentioned  Among the things for which those who came
after them are criticized is that they bear
witness but do not seek testimony. Several interpretations of this have been offered. The
first interpretation is that it means
perjury, as narrated by al-Tirmidhi from some scholars. The
second interpretation is that it refers to swearing
falsely by God, as stated by al-Tahawi. Al-
Khattabi said it means bearing witness to unseen matters concerning
people's fate in Paradise or Hell. It has also been said, as
Sheikh Ibn Uthaymeen stated, that it means someone who comes to bear
witness but is not qualified to do so. This
also contains an encouragement to trustworthiness, a prohibition against treachery, and an obligation to fulfill
vows. The statement that
obesity will become prevalent among them
means that they love to indulge in food
and drink,
becoming excessive and wasteful in this regard. This is one of the reasons for listening to
music.
Then he mentioned the hadith of
Abdullah, may God be pleased with him,
on the authority of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, who
said: "The best of people are my generation, then those who follow them, then
those who follow them."
Then, after them will come a people whose testimony precedes their oath.
Their faith is their testimony,
and these people
combined false testimony with a
false oath. This is the aspect of the sin if he said, "
Their testimony precedes their faith."
[Music]
Then he mentioned the hadith of
Qays, who said, "I heard Khabbab, who had been cauterized
seven times on his stomach that day, narrating the
hadith of Khabbab, and he
said, 'Were it not that the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, forbade us from praying for death, I would have prayed for death.' God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said, 'The
Companions of Muhammad, may God bless him and grant him peace, passed away, and the world did not diminish them in any
way. May God bless him and grant him peace. And if we acquire
from the world what we cannot find a place for
except the dust,
this also indicates that the Companions, may God be pleased with
them, left the world behind them. And his
saying here, 'And if we acquire from the world what we cannot find a place for except the dust,'
has the meaning of the world's vastness
for him, meaning that he amassed wealth that he could not find a place to spend except on
buildings.
The dust means the buildings.
This is an indication of the abundance of wealth and the conquests among the
Muslims.
Wealth became so plentiful that a person could not find anyone to spend it on him due to
the abundance of the rich.
[Music]
Unlike those who passed away from the Companions, most of whom were
poor.
As for the issue of ruling  Wishing for death
is said to be better for a
believer
who does good deeds than death. This is because the Prophet (
peace and blessings be upon him) said, "The best of people is he whose
life is long and whose deeds are good."
Therefore, the virtue of the man who died later than
his companion, and the
first one was a martyr,
was mentioned. The Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) was asked about this
when he saw him in a vision, and he was better than the first. He said, "Didn't he
fast Ramadan after him and pray 6,000 rak'ahs or
so?" meaning his life was longer.
Therefore, the
Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) forbade
wishing for death,
as in the hadith of Abu Hurairah: "None of
you should wish for death,
nor should he supplicate to
God Almighty for it,
nor should he supplicate for it before it comes to him. For when
one of you dies, his deeds cease."
And nothing increases a believer's life except good.
In another narration, it says, "None of
you should wish for death, but if he is a doer of good, perhaps he will increase."  As for the
wrongdoer, perhaps he will repent
or be made to repent, meaning he will repent, may
God bless him and grant him peace.
But if he fears temptation for himself, then he may supplicate and
say, "O God, keep me alive
if life is better for me, and cause
me to die if death is better." And
as it came in the supplication, "
And if You intend to test Your servants, then
take me to You without being tested." And if any convocation takes, it was narrated to us,
Qais narrated to me, he said, "I came to Khabbab, and he was building a
wall
[music], and
he said, 'Our companions who passed away did not diminish
the world in any way, and if we gain anything after them, we will find no place for it
except the dust.'" And he
mentioned after that, on the authority of Khabbab, may God be pleased with him, he said, "
We emigrated with the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace," a
story
[music], may
God be pleased with him, may God bless him and grant him peace. And
he meant by that the hadith, "We emigrated with the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace. And some of us passed away
without consuming any of
his reward, including Mus'ab ibn 'Umair, may God bless him and grant him peace [
music]. And
this will also be mentioned in the following hadiths
[music].
He said, Chapter: The saying of God Almighty, "O mankind, indeed the
promise of God - let not the promise of God
deceive you."  The life of this world, and let not the deceiver deceive you concerning God. Indeed,
Satan is an enemy to you, so take him as an enemy. He
only invites his party to be among the people of magic. He gathered a
price or a price. Mujahid said: The deceiver is Satan.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, said: God Almighty is
notif
and notief the concerning God is surely an
enemy to you, so take him
only. He
mentioned the hadith of
Uthman, may God be pleased with him,
that he performed ablution and did it very well, then he said: I
saw the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him,
perform ablution in this gathering and did it very well. The
hadith of Uthman bin Affan, may God be pleased with him, peace and blessings be upon him,
then he said: Whoever performs ablution like this ablution, then comes to the
mosque and prays two rak'ahs, then sits, his past sins will be forgiven, peace and blessings be upon him. And
the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: Do not be deceived.
God, peace and blessings be upon him,
here he explained
this virtue, which is the virtue of one who performs ablution and does it very well,
then prays two rak'ahs, that it is among the reasons for the
forgiveness of past sins. And
his saying in the chapter: The deceiver. And he said: The deceiver is Satan. The
deceiver is everything that deceives and deludes a person,
and he was interpreted as Satan because he is the head or the head in
that.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, and
his saying here  Peace and blessings be upon him. Do
not be deceived after he mentioned that ablution or sitting
for prayer is a cause of forgiveness. This means
that
you, O servant, should
not take forgiveness in its general sense and use it as an excuse
to persist in sins and not repent. Peace and blessings be upon him.
The prayer
that is the cause of forgiveness of sins is
ablution and prayer accepted by God. You do not
know
whether God has accepted your deeds and prayers or not. God,
the Exalted, the Almighty, the Majestic, the Blessed, the Most High.
Or the meaning could be that it
expiates minor sins, so do
not make that a
reason for not repenting from major sins.
He said, "Chapter on the Departure of the Righteous." It is said that the
rain has departed. May
God have mercy on him. He
mentioned the hadith of Mirdas ibn Malik al-Aslami. The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "The righteous will depart, one after another, and only the dregs will remain, like the
dregs of barley or dates.
God will not care about them." Abu Abdullah, meaning
al-Bukhari,
said, "It is said that the dregs are the dregs." The hadith of
Mirdas.
Peace and blessings be upon him. Al-Aslami.
Mirdas al-Aslami. God, peace and blessings be
upon him.
People die
after other people, and this refers to
the righteous
among the worshippers and scholars, and
their passing away means their death.
This is like the Prophet's saying, peace and blessings be upon him, that God does not take away knowledge by snatching
it from people's hearts,
but by taking away the scholars.
God Almighty
[music]
God does not take away knowledge by snatching it from
men's hearts, but by taking away the scholars. When the
scholars are gone, there will
not remain a single scholar among them.
People will then take ignorant leaders who will issue rulings without knowledge, thus going astray and leading others astray.
God Almighty [taki]
people take leaders.
And his hadith, "The righteous will pass away first," means that the righteous scholars will pass
away.
This also indicates that the death of righteous scholars is one of the
signs of the Hour.
He said, "And the dregs will remain." The dregs or refuse
are the worst of everything,
or the last of the bad dates that are not
used. The dregs are the last of the bad dates that are not used. The meaning is that the dregs of
people will remain, and that God does not
care, meaning He does not raise their status or
give them any weight.
God Almighty,
as in another narration, does not care about them at all.
This, O noble ones, is from  God Almighty's punishment for
us is that the righteous pass away and die, may
God Almighty be pleased with them.
This is what we have witnessed and
experienced: the
passing of scholars like
Baz, Al-Albani, Al-Haydan, Sheikh Muqbil, Sheikh Ubayd, and
Al-Najm,
until we lost
our Sheikh, Sheikh Rabi'. I ask God Almighty to
forgive him and grant him spacious gardens in Paradise. The
beloved of God Almighty, Al-
Albani,
Ubayd Ahmad Al-Najm, Sheikh
Ubayd,
Sheikh Rabi'.
In this hadith, there is an indication
of the obligation to emulate the people of goodness and knowledge,
that the servant should be among the righteous and knowledgeable.
He strived to seek the
hadith,
saying, "Chapter on what to be wary of regarding the trial of wealth: God Almighty
says, 'Your wealth and your children are but a trial.'"
This was narrated by Imam Al-Bukhari, may God have mercy on him.
[Music]
The meaning of His saying, "Your wealth and your children are but a trial," is that they
distract the servant from obedience to God Almighty. This is as the Prophet, peace
and blessings be upon him, said: "Every nation has a trial, and the trial of this nation is
wealth."
The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, recited this
verse when he was giving a sermon.  Al-Hasan and Al-Husayn came wearing two
red shirts.
He descended from the pulpit, picked them up,
and placed
them before him. Then he said, "God and His Messenger have spoken the truth: '
Your wealth and your children are but a trial.'" (Peace and blessings be upon him).
Husayn (Peace and blessings be upon him) delivered a sermon.
[Music]
Then he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurayrah (may God be pleased with him): The
Prophet (Peace and blessings be upon him) said, "Wretched is the slave of the
dinar and the dirham! Wretched is the slave of the dinar and the dirham! The velvet and
the fine garment—if he is given, he is pleased, and
if he is not given, he is displeased." The
Imam (may God have mercy on him) said, regarding the hadith of Abu Hurayrah (
may God be pleased with him):
God (Peace and blessings be upon him) said, "The
dirham..."
[Music] His saying, "
Wretched," means fallen or perished.
[Music] And "slave of the dinar" here means servitude, the meaning of which is mentioned, meaning immersion in something, which becomes his desire, for which he offers everything. [Music] And
the velvet and the fine garment are types of clothing that they
loved. The
hadith
says, "If he is given, he is pleased, and if he is not given, he is displeased." This is one
of the characteristics of the hypocrites:
if they are given some of it, they are pleased, and if they are not given some of it, then they are
displeased,
because their standard is...  Money and worldly possessions,
not obedience to God and His pleasure,
as
he and others have
said, are the characteristics
of the hypocrite. Why? Because when they
are given something, they are satisfied; when they are not given something, they are dissatisfied. They use the way
things are
in terms of their pleasure and
satisfaction. The world and its affairs are what they value. [The following appears to be a separate, unrelated fragment:]
He mentioned
the hadith of Ibn Abbas:
I heard the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, say: If
the son of Adam had two valleys, he would not need a third. Nothing fills the
stomach of the son of Adam except dust. And God accepts the repentance of
whoever repents.
[The following appears to be a separate, unrelated fragment:] Adam had two valleys of money and worldly possessions. And it may fill his stomach. And in another narration: It does not fill his eyes. And in another narration: It does not fill his mind. [Music] He
combined that because
the mouth is the
path to the stomach. [Music] And
the eye, because it is the origin of the desire. He sees what
pleases him, then after that he puts it in his mouth, and it reaches
his stomach. [Music]
Most of what is sought is money to obtain pleasures.
Among the greatest pleasures are food and drink.
Why
is it necessary for
a person to be satisfied with his
stomach, and he requires that which will
satisfy
We continue this.
God is the
Greatest,
God is the Greatest, God is the
Greatest. I bear
witness that there is no god but God.
[Music] I
bear witness that there is no god but God. I bear
witness that Muhammad is the Messenger of God. I bear
witness that Muhammad is the Messenger of God. Come
to prayer. Come to prayer. Come to success. Come to success. God is the Greatest,
God is the Greatest. There is
no god but God. As for his saying, "
Nothing fills the stomach of the son of Adam except dust,"
it was said that its meaning is
that he who was created from dust will not be
satisfied except by dust. He has been entrusted with a lion that has been entrusted with a
lion. And it was
said that its meaning is that his greed will not end until he
dies. So when he dies, he is buried and dust is poured upon him, and the
dust fills his stomach and his eyes. And he
said the meaning of this is that nothing will fill the stomach of the son of Adam except dust. And dust is upon him. After mentioning the way to salvation from what he has fallen into of love of the world, which is repentance to God Almighty, and God accepts the repentance of whoever repents, an indication of the obligation of repentance from sins to God Almighty. And he mentioned the hadith of Ibn Abbas, who said, "If Adam had a valley full of
wealth, he would love to have someone like it. Nothing
fills the eyes of the son of Adam except dust, and God accepts the repentance of
whoever repents." Ibn said  Abbas said, "I do not know if it is from
the Quran or not." He
said, "I heard Ibn al-Zubayr say that on the pulpit."
The Imam, may God have mercy on him,
Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with them both, peace be
upon him, said, "
Adam equ
will anothered nothing can satisfy them son except for fores
the said not
was."
This is similar in meaning to the previous hadith,
but it includes his statement, "I do not know if it is from the Quran or not."
Scholars have two opinions on this.
Ibn Hajar, may God have mercy on him, mentioned two opinions.
The first is that
when they heard this, they thought it was from the Quran because of its condemnation of
greed for worldly possessions, may God have
mercy on him.
When Surah At-Takathur was revealed,
they knew that the first was from the words of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.
This is as narrated by
Anas on the authority of Abu, as will be mentioned later. He said, "We used to consider
this to be from the Quran until Surah At-Takathur was revealed." The
second opinion
is supported by several narrations, which state that it was part of the
Quran, then its recitation was abrogated. This was
mentioned by several scholars who wrote on abrogation,
including Ibn Hazm al-Jawzi and Abd al-Barr
Hazm.
[Music] This is
supported by what is found in Sahih Muslim on the authority of Abu
Musa al-Ash'ari.
He said, "
Yes,
al-Ash'ari. We used to
recite a surah that
we considered similar in length and intensity to Surah At-Tawbah (Bara'ah
). I have
forgotten it, except that I memorized from it, 'If the
son of Adam had the like of
[music]...' Rather, it
came in Musnad Ahmad with a sound chain of narration, which
Sheikh Al-Albani authenticated, stating
on the authority of Ibn Abbas that he recited it to him, and his
father, may God be pleased with him, recited it to him. Imam
Ahmad, may God have mercy on him, Sheikh Al-
Albani, may God have mercy on him,
then he mentioned the hadith of Ibn Az-Zubayr,
who used to say, 'O people, the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, used to
say, "If the son of Adam were given a valley full of
gold, he would desire a
second, and
if he were given a second, he would desire a third. Nothing fills the
stomach of the son of Adam except dust, and God accepts the repentance of whoever
repents."'
This shows the extreme greed of the son of Adam, except for those on whom God has mercy.
Zubayr, may God be pleased with him,
mentioned the hadith of Anas that the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him,
said, 'If the son of Adam had a valley full of gold, he would desire two
valleys, and nothing fills his mouth except
dust, and God accepts the repentance of whoever repents.'
The hadith of Anas, may God be pleased with him, and
all these hadiths indicate the condemnation of greed."  The explanation
of this world is that most of the early Muslims were inclined to reduce their attachment to
worldly things and be content with little.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Anas on the authority of Abu, who said, “We used to consider this to be
from the Quran until the verse ‘The mutual rivalry for worldly gain diverts you’ was revealed.” This has already been mentioned.
The meaning of “The mutual
rivalry for worldly gain diverts you” is that it preoccupies you in a way that leaves you without excuse. Here, as Ibn al-Qayyim said, it refers to the pursuit of anything: wealth, status, leadership, or even the pursuit of hadith or knowledge. [Music] Or the pursuit of books. But if the intention is not obedience, seeking knowledge with the correct intention, but rather for the sake of increasing and competing,
such things, just to
be more than others and to be pointed out, not for the sake of God, the Exalted, the Almighty, the Most High ...